من رفح الان معنا رائد النمس المتحدث باسم
الهلال الاحمر في قطاع غزه ضيفنا اذا ما
هي المعلومات المتوفره عن المناطق الغربيه
من خانيونس والتي تشهد قصفا واطلاق نار
وتسبب هذه الحاله من الاصابات وحتى
الشهداء والهلع في صفوف
النازحين اهلا بكم في الواقع يعني
تستمر الغارات الاسرائيليه سواء كانت يعني
المدفعيه او من طيران الحربي الاسرائيلي
على مدار الثلاثه ايام المتواصله بشكل
مكثف في محيط مستشفى الامل ومقر الجمعيه
في خان يونس والذي يعني يعلم جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي جيدا بوجود اكثر من 13000 من
العائلات النازحه متواجدين في هذا المكان
بالاضافه الى المرضى والمصابين الذين
يتلقون العلاج في المستشفى ولكن يبدو ان
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يصر على
عمليه اجلاء المرضى والعائلات النازحه
والكادر الطبي الموجود في هذه المستشفى
وفي هذا المقر تحت يعني وابل من الرصاص
و خلق حاله من الاصابات والشهداء باعداد
كبيره بهدف اجبار المنطقه وهي منطقه غرب
خانيونس والتي يعني اذا ما تم اخلاء مقر
جمعيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني فان هذا
يعني اخلاء جميع السكان هناك وهذا ما
يريده الجيش الاسرائيلي وهذا ما ترفضه
اداره جمعيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
وتواصل عملها في يعني
اسعاف
وتطبيب المرضى والمصابين رغم حاله الخطر
المستمره منذ اكثر من 48 ساعه وعدم قدره
الطواقم على الخروج والدخول الى مقر
الجمعيه ومقر الاسعاف والمستشفى مما دفعنا
لانشاء نقاط طبيه اسعافيه خارج المقر بهدف
ضمان الوصول الى الحالات التي يتم
استهدافها في مناطق اخرى من محافظه
خانيونس
ماذا
بخصوص المناطق يعني الى اين يهرب ان
النازحون
وكذلك اهالي خان يونس في هذه الحاله بفعل
تواجد اليات واطلاق نار هل من طرق لهم
للانتقال من منطقه الى منطقه في هذه
الاثناء يعني في هذه الاثناء ومنذ ليله
امس تحديدا
يعني المداخل والمخارج الى محافظه خان
يونس شبه معدومه في الوقت الحالي وذلك
بسبب استهداف الطيران الاسرائيلي او
الدبابات الاسرائيليه على حد السواء لاي
جسم متحرك في هذه المناطق سواء كان في
محيط مستشفى ناصر او محيط مستشفى الامل
وهي بالمناسبه مناطق يعني جغرافيه كبيره
يعني نحن على سبيل المثال نعاني جدا في
القدره الىى الوصول او التحرك من هذه
المناطق رغم طبي وضوح طبيعه مهامنا الصحيه
والانسانيه الا ان يعني كل من الدبابات
الاسرائيليه وايضا الطائرات المسيره
تستهدف الجميع بلا هواده من م ما يشكل
يعني خطرا كبيرا على حياه الاف المواطنين
هناك سواء من كانوا بداخل جمعيه الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني او من السكان المحيطين
في تلك المناطق ونحن بدورنا في الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني كنا قد اشرنا بان هذه
تعد جرائم حرب اسرائيليه واضحه وعلانيه
ويجب على المجتمع الدولي ان يتدخل لايقاف
هذه الاعتداءات التي تطال المدنيين
والكوادر الطبيه على حد السواء لو تحدثنا
الان عن الاصابات وكذلك اعداد الشهداء
هنالك مناشدات وشهود عيان يتحدثون عن
اطلاق نار بشكل مباشر على النازحين ما ي
ما الذي يصلكم من معلومات حول هذه الحاله
وهذه الحوادث والمناطق ايضا التي يتم
استهداف النازحين
فيها يعني في ظل تقطع الاتصالات في محافظه
خان يونس وتعمد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
التشويش على يعني شبكه الاتصالات الخاصه
بالطواقم الطبيه في الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني وغرفه العمليات المركزيه فان
المعلومات تصل شحيحه ولكن اخر ما وصلنا هو
وجود عدد من الشهداء والاصابات بالعشرات
والطواقم الطبيه تحاول الان العمل مع هذه
الحالات ولكن تم استهداف صباح هذا اليوم
ايضا الطابق الرابع لمقر جمعيه الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني وكان هناك وجود لطائرات
مسيره تطلق النار بشكل عشوائي على
العائلات النازحه وبالتالي هناك عدد كبير
من الشهداء والاصابات ولكن لا رقم دقيق
حتى الان لان هذه الهجمه لا لا زالت
مستمره حتى هذه اللحظات ويقوم الجيش
الاسرائيلي باستهداف اي جسم متحرك مما
يعيق قدره المسعفين والكوادر الطبيه على
اسعاف واجلاء ونقل المصابين ما حاله
المستشفيات سواء في مستشفى الامل او حتى
في مستشفى ناصر بعدما اصبحت محاصره ولا
ولا ولا امكانيه لخروج او دخول الفرق
الطبيه والاسعافات اليها ما الذي يجري
داخل المستشفيات حسب
معلوماتكم
يعني ربما تعلمون بان هناك اكثر من 30
مستشفى على مستوى قطاع غزه من اصل 36
مستشفى تم توقفها عن العمل جراء الاستهداف
ونفاذ الوقود والمستلزمات الطبيه وبالتالي
كلا من مستشفى ناصر ومستشفى الامل عليها
عليهما عبئ كبير وذلك لانهم من المستشفيات
القليله التي بقيت تواصل خدماتها الطبيه
وان كانت بامكانيات محدوده جدا فكلاهما
يعانيان من عدم توفر الوقود اللازم لتشغيل
جميع الاقسام وكلاهما يعملان وفق سياسه
ترشيد بال
للموارد المتاحه ولمست الطبيه وهناك شح
كبير ونقص في ادوات التخدير والتعقيم فما
بالكم الان وهم محاصرات ويوجد اطباق
اسرائيلي كامل عليهم من جميع النواحي
وبالتالي لا يتم ادخال اي من المساعدات
الخاصه بادوات الجراحه والتعقيم والتخير
فالامر الصحي هناك يزداد سوءا ويجب ان
يكون حل جذري وسريع لهذه المساله لكي لا
يسقط المزيد من الضحايا ماذا بخصوص
الامدادات
على قلتها كما قلت ما تاثير هذه العمليات
العسكريه وتواجد هذه الاليات في في
المنطقه الغربيه او في شوارع خان يونس
الرئيسيه على وصول ايه امدادات طبيه او
حتى فرق الى الى مستشفى الامل او حتى
مستشفى
ناصر يعني هذا ما نخشى ان يتكرر فيه او
عبره السيناريو الذي حدث مع شمال غزه
وعندما تم فصلها عن باقي محافظات قطاع غزه
وتم قطع الامدادات عنها سواء كانت
الانسانيه او الصحيه او الغذائيه والطبيه
ايضا وبالتالي اذا ما نجح الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في فرض هذا الطوق الامني على
محافظه قن يونس وفصلها عن باقي المحافظات
فان هذا سيعني حرمانها ايضا من جميع
المساعدات سواء كانت الاغاثه او الغذائيه
او الطبيه وهذا س ما سيحول ايضا حياه
السكان هناك الى مزيد من ال الكوارث
الانسانيه والصحيه l